welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and wanda vision just revealed an
avenger origin story monica rambo
transforming into photon or spectrum i
assume she'll go by the name photon
since that was her mom's call sign but
either way a hero
inspiring kids everywhere to break
barriers expose themselves to radiation
no protective gear okay kids maybe don't
try that at home especially if you live
near a power plant
but there's still a lot we don't know
about monica like what are her
powers and how do they work exactly why
is her anatomy unique so that radiation
exposure supercharges her while giving
no apparent superpowers to
others in the hex well by looking into
the visual clues from episodes plus the
wonderful tiana paris's latest hints and
interviews
and other details we picked up about her
secret history with captain marvel we
can start to figure out why this origin
story is being kept so under wraps
because maybe big reveals coming folks
just look how damn excited tiana is
after episode 7 she explained to jimmy
kimmel monica's powers
monica can absorb energy
in the comics that is what her
superpower is
it is yet to be revealed just exactly
what it is
in the mcu we we get a taste of the fact
that there is something that has changed
and we have to stay tuned to find out
exactly how that will manifest itself
but in the comics she can absorb all
energy on the electromagnetic spectrum
yeah notice that tiana specified in the
comics there so the story will be a bit
different in the mcu but to go a bit
more into that comics history
monica rambo actually held the mantle of
captain marvel
before carol danvers did in the late 80s
when carol was going by the name miss
marvel
decades before her 2011 relaunch that
inspired the mcu version of the
character
monica later going by the names photon
and spectrum
actually harnesses her energy from
another dimension this is a case with
quite a few marvel comics heroes
nightcrawler technically teleports to
the brimstone dimension in between
destination points in our dimension
cyclops's optic blasts technically come
from portals in his eyes
to another dimension but essentially
spectrum monica can turn into a wave of
electromagnetic energy
capable of moving at the speed of light
absorbing or expelling
all kinds of radiation like captain
marvel it's a bit ill-defined which
is why i am so glad wandavision seems to
be putting it into clearer terms now the
series right now
made it seem like these powers only
emerged in episode 7
the moment monica shoved through the
barrier it's a beautiful sequence
mixing the voices of monica's past and
splitting monica into a spectrum of her
various selves
in order of her priorities in life
daughter then
explorer then sword agent then rescuer
so that her final step
merges all these as an avenger it also
gives us a kind of visual language of
how
wanda might use this hex to split
reality into a multiverse
the visuals pull a projection of
monica's face out of her
borrowing scott derrickson's homage to
contact during dr strange's multiverse
trip
a spectrum of realities aka a multiverse
one that eventually collapses back into
one reality with that traveler
changed and in monica's case her eyes
now glow
blue as she can see the radiation
coursing through the surfaces
of the town within the west view hex now
i keep comparing this to neo seeing the
matrix code
that is obviously the reference point
monica can see the illusion's machinery
meaning she
is immune to the smoke and mirrors that
also goes for the post-credits scene in
which her eyes glow
purple as she sees agatha's purple magic
flowing through the vines rather than
monica being a captive of that magic i
think this just means she can see
it whereas others in hex can only see
whatever agatha wants him to see but
just to be clear about the rules here
does the hex radiation give
everyone exposed to it these same kind
of powers like darcy agent monty
agent franklin the beekeeper other sword
agents in west view residents
well clearly not i'm sorry to disappoint
your phoenix theories last i checked
phoenix doesn't ride a unicycle
yet monica's physiology was weird to
begin with before
all this after her blip back in episode
four she wrecks a dude taller than her
just by bumping into him
after her expulsion from the hex her
x-ray scans
show up blank and she just shrugs them
off weirdly
wanda was surprised to see her still
alive afterward but you are the one in
control
you're still here
in episode six she similarly waved off
darcy's warnings that the radiation was
affecting her dna at the molecular level
and craziest if you watch closely right
before the third pass
monica rips the rover hatch off its
hinges
god damn are we sure this isn't a
she-hulk origin story monica clearly
already had some kind of powers and she
knows it that's why she initially
just stuck her hand in the probe despite
jimmy saying not to do it so really the
question now becomes
what happened to monica in the past to
make her this way but before we continue
thank you to bang energy for sponsoring
this video
every can of bang energy has zero
calories zero carbs zero
sugars and zero artificial flavors each
16 ounce can contains
milligrams of caffeine super creatine
coq10
and bcaas i am sipping on rainbow
unicorn not like those thundercloud
unicorns the unicorns that make you feel
happy when you sip them it's just sweet
and light like you're on the back of a
unicorn
leaping over a more depressed unicorn i
honestly rely on bangs when i'm shooting
those early morning after shows and i
don't want my eyes to look like i'm half
asleep when i'm trying to break down
these easter eggs i need my mind to be
alert
check out bang on instagram you can get
10 off your order at dangenergy.com when
you use the code new rockstars 10.
rainbow there you can buy a variety pack
of bang energy or grab a 12 pack of
citrus twist
bankster berry the new delish strawberry
kiss
use my code new rockstars 10 and receive
off your bang energy order that's code
new rockstars 10 for
10 off captain marvel must be involved
you've noticed how monica cringes every
time carol is brought up
well i'd argue that captain marvel came
close
her powers came from an infinity stone
too right we
are not talking about her we are talking
about
wanda i know your history with carol
danvers
and all you people who left my mother
would appreciate your loyalty
she's not the only one we're loyal to
captain
monica's memories with carol that we saw
in captain marvel echo
in her mind the moment she blipped back
and during her transformation
lieutenant trouble your mom's lucky
when they were handing out kids they
gave her the toughest one and nick fury
saying glow like your aunt carol is
key there must have been some past
incident in which monica joined carol
came out of that radioactive sorry to
get dark here but
maybe even the radiation that gave maria
cancer
came from hugs from her daughter it's
sad i know
but that grief could have led to captain
marvel's absence from earth until 2018
when she coolly told off rhodey that she
was just too busy to help them protect
earth and if you don't mind my asking
where the hell have you been all this
time there are a lot of other planets in
the universe
and unfortunately they didn't have you
guys so i see two paths that explain
monica's past oneovision could go the
mutant route to suggest that monica
rambo might have been born with the
x-gene as wanda likely was and that's
why cosmic radiation gives them
powers and not powers to everyone else
who gets exposed
radiation is just activating something
in their dna that was there when they
were born but alternatively
monica's physiology could be the result
of a past space mission
say cosmic rays that hit monica along
with
other sword astronauts which would give
us the fantastic four
now i'm still not convinced her mystery
engineer is reed richards but
tiana and kimmel did joke about her
fantastic four-esque wardrobe
and now i see this um dress that you're
wearing
is very similar to the uniform of the
fantastic
four this is the easter egg
maybe that's the easter egg are you
gonna burst into flames or turn
invisible or
oh gosh in three two
not that that would make monica's one of
the fantastic four but the incident that
created them in the mcu could be the
same incident that set her up to
withstand the radiation of westview and
become photon what do you think broke
monica
you can support this channel by checking
out one of our great merch options at
newarkstarsmerch.com
like this unusual couple shirt follow me
on instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars subscribe to new rockstars
for all your wanna vision theories and
questions
thank you for watching bye
[Music]
you